Let me just so clarify. Yes, it is true
that if you're not around any Muslims
but in your heart you believe that
Allah's God and Muhammad is a messenger,
obviously from the perspective of Allah,
then he's not God, but let's assume he
is.
Then you are a Muslim. Yeah, that's
that's what Yasser Qadhi is saying. So
yes, from that perspective, if you are
not around any Muslims, but in your
heart you believe, then your Islam is
accepted. But once you encounter
Muslims, then you have to do it the
traditional way. So yeah, I understand
what he's saying. So but did you
eventually, after in your heart
embracing Islam and believing Muhammad
was his messenger, did you meet Muslims?
And if so
how do those interactions go and how
much time you spent in Islam and then
why did you leave? This is the whole
point. You have obviously you're no
longer Muslim, but why did you leave?
But work your way up to that point.
Okay, of course. And and my voice is
clear through here since the first time
I used Skype, so that's fine.
>> perfect.
Okay, all right. So
>> [clears throat]
>> okay, so yeah.
I made that kind of internal declaration
and then I taught myself how to do salah
like after
some videos like
cuz it was self-taught. I taught myself
how to do the the ritual like we'll do I
taught myself how to do salat.
Interesting. You know, it was all
self-taught.
But then I but then you also learn
because of that time I was also I was
watching a lot of Zakir Naik. I was
watching a lot of Shabbir Ally.
I was watching all the prominent names
at least in the English-speaking world
um for a super long time. That's that's
how I did it because of my area Muslim
population is very low.
So I the best thing I could do was just
learn how to pray, do it on time, read
the Quran every day, and then watch all
these speakers. That's what I did.
So eventually though I learned that
well, there was actually a mosque about
14 miles from where I live.
And they did have Jumu'ah prayer every
Friday.
And I would even take off work to go.
And I might and I met a lot of people
from like Pakistan, Saudi Arabia there,
Syria, Jordan.
>> [snorts]
>> But
uh and then and then I would and I
prayed with them, you know, I
me self-teaching myself how to do salah
how I was doing it with them. I mean, I
made a couple errors, you know, and they
corrected me on it or whatever it was,
but
they commended me on my journey and all
these things. But what I noticed about
all these speakers
and even it's in the Quran itself, like
the religion just teaches you to have to
do this.
You have to criticize Christianity. And
they would do that all the time. So they
would see me as like uh you know, a
Caucasian man who just converted
as like this avenue in which to attack
Christianity. Like you know, like they
would just do it all the time.
>> their golden goose. And a Caucasian
who doesn't look Middle Eastern or South
Asian, and you would be a great tool to
bring other Westerners to Islam out of
Christianity. Of course, they loved you.
Yeah, you're exactly right. So that's
how they treated me, you know, it's like
they were just kind of thrilled to talk
to me about these things and
all I could do was give them all the
things that I learned from listening to
all these speakers because I mean
all the all the speakers they I mean
they're not all unanimous on certain
things, but the generally they
they preach what they think is right,
you know, if it's as long as it's
Sunnah, it's from the Sunnah and it's
from the Quran, you know, that's the
that's kind of what they always did.
That's what they always preached. But
they would always criticize
Christianity. So
but then but then listening to more
Zakir Naik
you know, [clears throat] obviously
really bad idea, but looking back on it
the claims over and over again
would be you know, the classic where in
the Bible does it say Jesus is God?
Where does it say worship me? All these
things. And I used that.
And and that was in my head. I thought
those were like the supreme
the supreme [clears throat] arguments
that couldn't be beat.
And the and the interesting thing was
watching these lectures and these
speeches by these guys
>> [clears throat]
>> in the YouTube feed would be like David
Wood videos and your videos
like underneath all these because I'd be
and then sometimes I'd even type in
YouTube like Zakir Naik refuted and then
you get all your guys's videos and I'm
like So let me just repeat that. I
I'm sorry, I don't mean to cut you off.
So
thank the Lord Jesus and Nabeel Qureshi
that even though YouTube can be used by
the devil to propagate lies
the Lord Jesus also uses YouTube to
propagate the truth. So even when you
watch a Zakir Naik video, you'd have in
the suggested viewing David Wood's
videos and mine popping up, huh?
Pretty much, yeah. So what happened
there? Keep going. Your story's good.
>> So yeah, I watched I mean, I soaked up
all that material. I mean, I uh
even the last couple of years, last 3
years of my life, I've been
basically engaged in apologetics and
polemics
um almost every day for the last couple
of years, you know.
So I would listen to the complete
lectures that you guys would have, you
know, I would watch the complete ones.
I started off with X17 Apologetics first
uh
cuz I don't know if that at that time
your channel was
I mean don't take offense. I don't know
if it was as like popular with more
views.
>> But at that time I was studying Wood and
Nabeel's material first. Yeah, let me
not I don't mean to cut you off, but I
want to clarify. No, because I came late
I was a Johnny-come-lately to YouTube
because I didn't like
>> Yeah.
to do [clears throat]
sessions where I'm speaking or where
people can see me. I prefer to write. So
I jumped in the bandwagon way later.
David Wood is like the General C. Patton
when it comes to Christianity. He's a
genius. He sees the future and he's a
brilliant
strategist. So he knew YouTube was the
way to go and I didn't care for it. So
yeah, it's not as popular, but you know,
glory to God and I pray it's never about
popularity, but thank the Lord David was
there and thank the Lord Nabeel Qureshi,
God was pleased to make his sessions
popular all over the world because it
doesn't matter. It's not about me, it's
not about David Wood and I pray I mean
that. It's about the Lord Jesus being
glorified and he'll use a David Wood or
me. So thank the Lord for that. So you
started watching Nabeel Qureshi, you
said. So keep going. Yeah, yep. I
watched his testimony video. I watched
David Wood's testimony video.
So at that time too, but even watching
that and and then all the critiques of
like the sahih narrations and all that
stuff.
Uh
you know, I like I watched all these all
these criticisms, but then I would still
kind of keep practicing a little bit.
And I would you know, it's I was still
questioning.
But then what happened
is I met someone actually in person who
uh
and I guess yeah, I'll just keep going
until you stop me anyways, but
so
uh I met this person. He's quite older
than me
and he knew that I was a Muslim
actually and he just uh and I and I
would tell him that I watched these
videos. I'm like, well hey, have you
ever watched Zakir Naik videos? He's
like and he and he laughed at them
because he knew how jokable they were
and all these things.
And I and I asked him it's like, well,
okay, you're professing what he
professes the Catholic faith, but I
asked him uh
well, where in scripture does it say
like Jesus is God or worship him?
And right off the cusp, John 8:58.
I'm like, okay, well, what does that
say?
Uh you know, before Abraham was I am.
And I mean, me without having any
scripture knowledge
no Christianity background
like you can hear that and you still may
not know what it means.
So I just asked him to expound upon
that, you know, and
uh and then but then I would hear that
up I would hear that come up in debates.
Like cuz I watched all the hours and
hours and hours of
Wood and Shabbir's debates. Uh I even
listened to you and Shabbir's debate.
Uh I listened to
James White's debates with Ally. Yeah.
You know, I watched like almost every
single lecture and debate I possibly
could to be honest.
>> Yeah. And uh
so I was just kind of convinced. It's
like, well, Islam crumbles because it's
simply all the all of its criticism
against Christianity.
They're all just without any like actual
uh ground. Mhm. I guess is the way you
could put it.
So that's that's how I left it. No, my
my question would be I don't I want to
interject. So Go ahead, yeah. after
watching James White, David Wood, Nabeel
Qureshi and their debates, but it seems
like you watched mostly the debates with
Shabbir Ally.
I cuz you said you said
>> listened to like the two and a half hour
thing that
James White had with Yasser Qadhi. Uh
oh, I mean, I can't leave out like
Vander Films and Jay Smith's like
ministry. That stuff hit really hard
because I mean, I know I know you and
Wood take different approaches than he
does
in ministry like
I mean, I don't know if you need to
expound upon that, but I know that it's
a different approach.
>> Yeah, I want you to emphasize that. I
want you to say it again. Jay Smith
who is our brother in the Lord Jesus,
who's a warrior for Christ, may God
preserve him.
His stuff on
the historical archaeological data
destroying the traditional narrative, it
really had a huge impact on you?
Well, yeah, definitely. I mean
uh cuz you guys like when I say you guys
like you and you and Wood, especially
David Wood,
uh
from from my perspective, it was it was
definitely like Quran and like Hadith
criticism and answering all the
criticism they had.
But someone like Jay Smith would offer
more of a polemical approach where he
would just
Well, and he would admit that it wasn't
his material. Like he quoted a lot of
other outwardly material from a lot of
other scholars, especially from Europe
and all these things.
>> it popular.
>> Uh
Yeah, very very very popular. Even Even
Nabeel in his uh
like 7-hour lecture at Biola, which I
watched all of that.
Uh
at Biola University. Yeah, I watched all
of that.
>> hours. You were really hungry for the
truth and aching for the truth and and
so you would sit
for hours and you watched Nabeel
Qureshi's entire 7-hour lecture in Biola
on Islam?
Yeah, like multiple times to be honest.
I mean, if if it wasn't just watching
it, it'd be in my earphones like if I'm
at work or whatever it was.
And I mean, I even I in fact even
listened to uh
what is
What is that one channel online? Or is
it KT
KT something like online? It's where Jay
Smith lectures are on. They're all for
free. I don't know if you know what I'm
talking about.
>> See, now See, look how amazing you are.
I didn't even know this. I haven't
listened to Nabeel Qureshi's 7-hour
uh lecture on Islam from Biola, nor was
I aware there's a website or YouTube
channel that has Jay Smith's lectures.
You see, but the reason why I'm
emphasizing this is because whether you
know it or not,
you are proving
that the Bible is the living active word
of God and that the promises of the
Bible are true because what you just
demonstrated is
>> [clears throat]
>> the faithfulness of Jesus Christ in
doing what he says because the Bible is
his word. And the Bible says, "Ask,
seek, and knock."
Matthew 7:7-8.
And if you read it from verse 7 all the
way to 11 and Luke 11:11-13, the Lord
Jesus has promised and he has sworn
that when the spirit begins to work in a
person's heart, seek God, come to know
him so you can be saved. And the more
you yield to the spirit, the more you
ask and seek. Ask and you will receive
your answer. Seek and you will find and
knock will be opened to you. You,
whether you know it or not, are proving
the truth of the Bible that the Bible,
because it's God's word, all of its
promises are true and cannot be
falsified. So as you were seeking cuz
you hunger for the truth cuz the spirit
put that fire in you,
you are
coming to the truth of the Lord Jesus
Christ and seeing Islam for what it is.
So I just like I'm emphasizing that. So
then, what was the breaking point for
you and what year? When When do you in
your own mind
say, "This was it. This is the breaking
point. This is where I said Islam is
false. I can't be a Muslim anymore." Can
you recall that?
Yeah, I mean uh I only practiced for
probably about 6 to 8 months.
And just just through
again, I mean, I
I yeah, I did like I listened to
practically because Yeah, because even
Nabeel would talk about in his
his testimony or something like that, he
would talk about that he had this
like these days worth of lectures at
Biola and I found them.
And for the most part, I listened to all
of them.
And uh
that helped a lot. I mean, I I have all
three of his books
like with me.
>> you are hungry for the truth. You read
his autobiography.
Uh I read the majority of No God but One
Wow. uh by him.
I didn't read Answering Jihad yet even
though I have it. You're hungry, man.
You have a fire for truth. May the Lord
Jesus satisfy
your your hunger from it. Yeah, so
you've read most of No God but One and
you will be waiting
>> I would kind of it's it's it's
definitely a book that it's it's hard to
kind of read from cover to cover. I
mean, I was reading a lot of it just in
uh
in just in apologetical method. You
know, I would I would look at the topics
like in the in the table of contents
just to kind of get certain points down
so I can memorize them and kind of
internalize them more.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and then also like Anish or what is
it? How do you pronounce his name?
Sherrod? What's his first name?
>> praise the Lord. You even found him?
Yeah, actually I found I found Islam
Revealed by him like in a in a in uh I
don't know if you have Do you guys have
Books-A-Million? I don't know who's
listening.
>> BAM, Books-A-Million.
>> there was a used section
in the religious part and it had his
book. It's like I think it was like less
than $10, less than five. I picked that
up. I even watched
his debate with Deedat. You know, it's
just I mean, I was just I mean, I'm
still really involved in all this stuff.
I mean, uh No, good. Good. You're
hungry. Yeah, I listened to all that.
But yeah, I guess to answer your
question in a shorthand way,
I practiced from like 6 to 8 months.
It kind of all fell apart just because
every single objection they have
uh
can be answered with with Basically,
even if
anyone that even just from a historical
method to proving the crucifixion, like,
you know, like Craig's debate with Ali
and all these things. You know, like
even on those surfaces,
you logic says that you just have to
leave that religion. And then if you
study any of the Hadith stuff,
uh
you realize how just how perverted all
how perverted
all the teachings were.
And I mean, especially David Wood in his
videos definitely demonstrated that.
Beautiful.